foreign
housing in the Bay Area is
astronomically High we're like always at
the top of every list teachers salaries
tend to be on the lower end of those
list of earning income and I'm sure the
Bay Area tries to compete but there is
no competing a teacher salary is not
going to be able to afford you housing
in the Bay Area California is getting
more expensive we already know the gas
prices and food prices are going up rent
still is very very high for for people
the median home price is so high so it's
hard to live
it's really difficult on the teacher's
salary to make it in the Bay Area and
many jobs and there's many jobs I'm sure
that make less money than teachers but
we are so Tech heavy here and so we look
at our five years of education and we
put our hearts and souls into our
profession we just care about the kids
and we're just trying to make a
difference in our communities
but sometimes we can't be part of the
community because we have to find
housing far away
some teachers Drive quite a ways because
they do like our school like our school
district but they can't afford to live
in this area
our houses here go well over a million
closer to 2 million at this point and
when you're coming in with a teacher's
salary it's just that's not going to be
enough to ever qualify to buy a house on
your own in this area and so people tend
to have have to find communities farther
and farther away from where they work
where they can afford to either pay rent
or hopefully you know purchase a home I
could not afford to live in my school
district I mean maybe I could find a
little teeny apartment you know 400
square feet Studio but I also have an
adult son you know who lives with me and
so that wouldn't work I don't encourage
any young people to go into teaching
right now because of the many issues
that we face I do not feel that
California places a premium on their
teachers I don't think that there is
really an understanding for what
teachers are doing in 2022 and the scope
of our job and the amount of energy and
time so I think there's parents that
appreciate us I think there's some
administrators that appreciate us but as
a state I do not feel appreciated
California does not value teachers
enough
there are so many openings Nationwide
for teaching and especially in our area
they're not flocking because they can't
afford to live here on the price that
we're paid
new teachers I think need to be aware
I love teaching and I'm glad that I'm a
teacher I don't know honestly if I would
get into teaching now only because
financially it's so much more difficult
even though teacher salaries have raised
over the years they haven't raised in
comparison to what everything else has
raised